what should entrepreneurs study in
university so I got a great question for
my YouTube viewers love you guys Tassimo
who wouldn't say hi I'm going to watch
your videos on a daily basis as a matter
of fact I have two of your videos as my
morning routine Thank You Tassimo thanks
a lot for your work is life-changing I
would like to ask your help I'm applying
for college these days but I'm really
suffering aside what the study in
college as an entrepreneur I don't want
to end up as a professional after
graduation in other words what do you
think entrepreneurs ought of studying
universities that would be helpful on
the entrepreneurial process Thanks
Tassimo this is a fantastic question and
one that I feel personally connected to
because I had my first real success out
of the business that I started when I
was in university so I usually give
three steps but today I'm giving you
five steps on what to do and I hope that
it helps you on your journey
number one is small business classes you
want to take whatever small business
classes they have at your university and
there may be a whole program around it
or may just be one class I remember at
my university
I'm Communiversity of Toronto which is
one of the probably the most well-known
university in Canada and and pretty well
known around the world and they had one
class in entrepreneurship that's all
they had so I took that and and it was
honestly a little too simple I had
already started my business and I was
learning way more from from doing and
being in my business in that class but
but it's still helpful to have the
basics right if you have no background
you've never done anything around
entrepreneurship before it's helpful to
have some of the basics and whatever
classes they have there can help teach
you the side benefit of it is you're
also in a group right the people who are
in that class with of others who want to
be entrepreneurs too or have Inklings
and become entrepreneurs and so you may
make some great contacts great
connections great business partners by
going to the classes that are around
entrepreneurship and my first business
was out of university I was 19 years old
and it was with two
other students who are at the same
university as I was and that's how we
created the company that eventually I
built up and sold so take whatever
classes they have around
entrepreneurship number two classes
you're passionate about like anything
else if you want to have success you
have to be passionate about if you want
to be a successful entrepreneur then you
need to be passionate about what you're
doing and so use your opportunity and
university to learn about other subjects
that have nothing to do with business
but that you're excited about because
you'll find some way to infuse business
into it and that could be your first
mega success one of my favorite examples
here is Steve Jobs who the founder of
Apple and he dropped out of university
so he could drop in on classes that
dealt with typography and who's learning
about fonts and how to how to create
characters that look beautiful because
he was frustrated with the current fonts
on computer systems and when Apple first
came out with his first computers they
had beautiful typography and fonts built
in and that was one of the
differentiators one of the reasons that
people went to go use a Mac and so he
took this knowledge you know what does
sitting on a typography class and people
would look at that from the outside and
say what are you doing typography class
what does have to do with
entrepreneurship or starting your own
business and he may not have even known
at the time either but he found a way to
incorporate that passion of his into his
business to help make him successful so
look at the roster of classes that are
available and see what speaks to you
it's okay if it has nothing to do with
business maybe you're taking a history
class or computer class or or sports or
whatever it is you're taking something
that you feel passionate you have an
interest in because believe me that will
come back to pay really strong dividends
for you you will find a way to
incorporate that into your future
business number three entrepreneur
groups most universities in college have
an entrepreneur small business group it
may be a consulting group it may be
helping entrepreneurs get started and
giving them advice whatever it is you
want to join
and it does a couple things one it'll
start giving you a little bit of
experience so if it's an entrepreneur or
consulting group you can start working
with entrepreneurs and I'll give you a
little bit of a taste for what it's like
real world experiences that are just out
of a textbook and it also again
introduces you to more of the hardcore
entrepreneurs because the people who are
running and involved in those groups are
more likely going to be the people who
don't want to get a job afterwards I
want to go and launch their own business
and they're using this as testing ground
and so knowing those people will be
really helpful because when you're out
there in the world doing your own
company and you're struggling it's great
to have a network of other entrepreneurs
to talk to connect with share ideas
share resources share connections to
help each other grow so look for
whatever entrepreneur group is available
and join it and get involved number four
start your own business start on the
side do something right now you don't
have to wait for when you graduate to
start something even if it's not the
business you end up with just start
something now because you're going to
learn so much more from doing from the
practical knowledge of running a
business then you're going to learn from
a textbook or learning from a teacher
who isn't really an entrepreneur right
then we have guest lecturers come in who
are entrepreneurs and give advice but
your best learning is going to be from
doing so start something small now on
the side part time to start building up
your knowledge base and number five is
create your own class this isn't really
well known but in a lot of universities
and colleges you can create your own
class you can create your own credit by
working with one of the professors and
so what I did was I had my business and
I wanted to work with a professor to
create my own class and I went to
somebody in the marketing department and
we created a class about pricing and
basically what they do is they mentor
you you meet as often as you want to
meet as you set up with your professor
and at the end you have to create a
paper that you submit to them and they
grade it and give you a final mark so
you have no final exam the coursework is
a lot lighter because there is no
coursework it's whatever you decide as
long as you get the backing from
the professor's so I created this course
on pricing and I used it to support the
business that I had right look at look
back the step four start on the side I
had a business that was selling
scientific software and some of our
customers could be university labs and
so I was able to go in to the labs at my
University and ask some questions about
pricing and learn about what they were
doing learned about their their lab and
their setup and actually make a few
sales but I would never be allowed to go
in and sell but I could go in under a
university sponsored project to collect
data and research because that's what I
was doing from our coursework so it
teaches you how to run your own project
it gives you a little bit more project
management skills it allows you to pick
a topic that you're passionate about
that you want to learn about at that
time I wanted to really learn about
pricing and it may help the business
that you've started as well by giving
you some contacts and potentially some
of your own new customers so find the
professor who you can connect with and
create your own class with them
so to summarize the five steps take
small business classes take classes that
you're passionate about join
entrepreneur groups start your own
business and create your own class
believe for those are watching like the
video you can support me please by
clicking on the link in the description
below leave a comment let me know what
you think and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon